[Applause]
[Music]
hey you're back
and that's a good thing what I need you
to do is like follow and subscribe head
ILP and then hit the little bell icon of
this so you can be notified when new
compact talk comes up or when new flash
points come out or when new ILP
information runs that way you can be
notified but in order to get all the
great stuff that we have for you guys
you must hit the like button and you
must subscribe see something December
first I told you guys this is gonna be
the one that you wanted to see at the
end of the year Tyson Fury up against a
heavyweight champion of the world
Deontay Wilder and in this I'm not gonna
go into what the promotion is trying to
do I'm just going to go into the facts
like this channel is not about hoopla
and the gossip that goes along with
promoting fights this channel is all
about the facts how they look before
they get in the ring what they should do
in the ring to win and then we're gonna
get to those results now we can go into
the background on the fighters and I
would love to go into the background of
Deontay Wilder the answer well does the
undefeated champion who has knocked out
all his opponents that he has ever faced
in the ring now one fighter he fought
his Verne - Verne and vernest Verne they
went 12 rounds the first fight it was
circumstances that led to their 12th
round decision and Beyonce's favor but
the second time before them blast them
out in the first round
Deontay Wilder is such a force of nature
that it's hard to deny what it should
evitable when he fights you see he's an
Olympic bronze medalist that is not to
be understated anytime I've told you
that anyone has been in the Olympics or
has partaken in any Olympic Trials I'm
telling you that these people are forced
to be reckoned with because they fight
every style around the world so a lot of
people will tell you that Deontay Wilder
style is not conducive to something that
looks pretty he looks amateurish his
style fits him not everybody is who you
want them to be they are who they need
to be who they are to win see being
comfortable with oneself inside that
ring is exactly what you have to be you
can't go inside the ring trying to be
someone else or have doubt within
yourself this is what leads me to Tyson
Fury Tyson Fury has never lost inside
the ring he's lost outside the ring
but inside the ring he has never lost
and when I say he's lost outside the
ring I'm saying that he has lost to a
drug addiction obesity and depression
now this is not hearsay this is facts
stated by Tyson Fury himself and I only
bring these uh downfall all these
pitfalls into question in giving my
synopsis of what the fight should be and
giving my prediction of what the fight
will unfold into why what what would it
become because every fight is different
every fighter and every fight is
different no two fights are the same as
always uh if you would have the same
result like your knockout but to achieve
that knockout there are patterns that
need to be unlocked there are codes that
needs to be inputted to get to that
juncture that part that sweet science
the reason why we watch some people only
watch for a knockout and that means you
will always watch the ante Wilder some
people will watch to see nice boxing and
then that means you want to watch Tyson
Fury he's a little bit sloppy but when
these two fighters are standing side by
side Tyson Fury is the more traditional
boxer ok Deontay Wilder is the knock out
artists alright there's no two ways
about it he's an artist he paints a
picture now I have to explain how Tyson
Fury has become not the champion he's
become the contender and he I said he
never lost in the ring well he was
stripped of his belts when he could not
lose weight after he beat Vladimir
Klitschko and after he was stripped of
his belts those belts was gobbled up by
Joshua Anthony Joshua and Deontay Wilder
alright those are the two heavyweight
champions at this time ok so what types
of fury holds claim to is the linear
championship and beating Vladimir
Klitschko he became the linear champion
that means that you can trace that all
the way back to him and it pick his
titles out of the garbage can he took
him off of the champ in a 12 round
lackluster fight why I thought vitamin
Klesko wasn't at his best
enticing theory was Tyson Fury awkward
jab decent right hand not nothing
overwhelming a nice left hook on his
feet he's a very confident and competent
fighter
No Deontay Wilder won a bronze
championship bronze medal in the 2008
Olympics and the man has been on a tear
he's unapologetic but he's humble he's
brash ferocious he's everything that you
will want a champion to be he will be
that tryhard champion I'll give you a
for instance and one of his fights
he told bicep and broke a hand in the
same fight and still went on to knock
out his opponent
Deontay Wilder comes around every once
in a generation a very special fighter
Tyson Fury is a contender that you can
see a lot of fighters image in he
doesn't stand out too much in the sense
that he you could pick him out of the
crowd when he bleed beat vadoma Klesko I
was surprised actually you know I
thought Valerie Miller would do what
Vladimir does and get to a lackluster
win and whatever but Tyson Fury was
confident going into the fight and
nobody really gave him a chance
like nobody's giving him a chance here
so let's go into exactly what they need
to do to win this fight the keys to
victory for Tyson Fury will be to
utilize his jab his boxing IQ his high
IQ because he's very intelligent he's a
very intelligent boxer which he knows
how to set up the right hand he jabs he
moves he knows when to hold he knows how
to move his head he knows when to work
the body he knows how to work rounds
footwork is very important so what he
would have to use is his high boxing IQ
to keep Deon say while the off-balance
to cruise to a 12-round victory if a
couple of bumpy parts in the middle of
the fight you know what happened I
believe that he can navigate through it
now Deontay Wilder what he has to do to
win this fight said Tyson Fury up for
the right hand he has a left hook to hit
Tyson Fury in the head the body the face
the shoulder what he needs to do is to
be
Deonte he needs to be the heavyweight
champion of the world he needs to own
that ring like he does every time he
fights so what do I expect to happen
being that all this talk and every last
word was pure aggression leading up to
this day I literally had to stop
watching any type of telecast of the
weigh-ins or the the press conferences
because I was praying that they didn't
fight then and jeopardize the fight but
I believe that both both of them were
intelligent enough to get to this point
that we meet I fully expect the ante
while to go on there and to touch Tyson
Fury up to get him in trouble and to
finish him because that is exactly who
he is he is a finisher ken Tyson Fury
get Deonte in trouble yes Willie no I
believe Deontay Wilder 'he's mindset is
unbreakable unwavering and relentless
the level of courage that that man shows
when he steps into that ring is
unparalleled
if you don't believe me look at Elise
his last six fights as his confidence
has gone strictly through the roof
that's through his condition in his
respect of his body now I used those
words respect of your body because takes
in fury did not respect his body as a
boxer that's the first and fan and only
thing that you must adhere to the
respecting of your body because your
body is your tools to win that's your
job if you're a race car driver you
respect that race car right
you don't put crappy fuel inside the
engine if you want to win right well
take some fury put crappy fuel inside
his engine he was stripped of this title
because he failed to be in condition
enough to defend it mentally you have to
say he fell into a lapse of judgment
when it came to using drugs and excess
so no I don't believe that you can abuse
your body balloon up to 400 pounds drop
down to 260 and getting the ring and
beat the heavyweight champion of the
world who has always been in tip-top
shape every fight dating back to the
Olympics Tyson Fury has already won he
has come back from a drug addiction he
has come back from obesity he has
reached his peak but there's a
gatekeeper standing at the door named
Deontay Wilder you will not get a
championship sir you'll get some stars
though you will see them stars you won't
be a
but you will see them stars this is
combat talk with the king catch on them
all
[Applause]
[Music]